Transcriber: Fadia ElMoubarak
المدقّق: Heba Tariq
(تصفيق)
صباح الخير،
معي خمس أسئلة لتساعد أي شخص في أي مكان
ليعيش حياة تشبهه أكثر، أي حياة عظيمة،
أول سؤال الآن ليس من ضمن الأسئلة الخمسة
التي أريد أن أطرحها عليكم لاحقاً،
من منكم يسكن في شقة سكنية داخل مجمع سكني؟
حسناً، من يملك جار سيئ؟
(ضحك)
أي يأخذ موقف سيارتك، أو يغلق بسيارته عليك،
لا يدفع الجزء المخصص عليه من الفاتورة،
أو الشيء الأسوء من كل ما سبق،
أن يقوم بالتدخين داخل المصعد،
(ضحك)
علاقة هذا الجار معك أنه يفكر فقط بنفسه،
ويعتبرك غير موجود، وعلاقة هذا الجار مع
بقية سكان العمارة أنه يفكر بنفسه أيضاً،
ويعتبرهم غير موجودين، هذا الجار يعتبر
الجميع غير موجودين،
وهنا ينطبق المثل العربي العظيم،
"كوم حجار أفضل من هذا الجار"،
إذا كنت لا تمتلك من نوعية هذا الجار،
أولاً، عليك أن تشكر الله ثم ثانياَ،
عليك أن تعيد التفكير ربما تكون أنت هذا
الجار،
(ضحك)
يقول ديكارت، "أنا أفكر إذاً أنا موجود"،
ولكن تخيلوا أننا جميعاً نفكر بأنفسنا فقط،
7.5 مليار شخص على كوكبنا الجميل،
كل شخص منا يفكر بنفسه فقط،
وتخيلوا أن الكوكب مليء بهذا الجار،
فقط من أمثاله، كيف سيكون شكلنا؟
كارثي.
لذلك لننتقل من "أنا أفكر إذاً أنا موجود"،
لتصبح أنا أفكر بالغير إذاً أنا موجود،
أنا أفكر بأثري على الغير إذاً أنا موجود،
هنا أصبح قبل أن أتصرف أرى هل سيؤثر على
شخص آخر؟
وهنا يأتي المصطلح اللطيف، "تنتهي حريتك
عندما تبدأ حرية الآخرين"،
لنتخيل أن حريتي هي الدائرة هذه، أستطيع أن
أمشي داخلها من غير أن أؤذييك أو أغضبك،
ومثلما أنا لدي هذه الدائرة الحمراء، هي
مساحتي،
أنت تخيل أيضا أنك تمتلك أسفل قدميك دائرة
حمراء وتذهب معك أينما ذهبت،
أحب أن أعرفكم على الأخلاق، هذه الدائرة هي
الأخلاق،
داخل الأخلاق أستطيع أن أذهب وأجيء بحرية،
ولكن عندما أتعدى الأخلاق أنا فعلياً قمت
بالتعدي على شخص ما،
وهذه ليست بعلاقة صحية، العلاقات التي تكون
بالتعدي خارج دائرة الحرية وخارج الأخلاق
هي علاقات تنتهي، مثل علاقة الجار.
هل أنا جار سيء؟
هذه العلاقة يمكن أن تكون ما بين أشخاص
لا يعرفون بعضهم البعض،
مثلاً كشخصين يمشيان بسيارتهما جانب بعضهما
في الشارع،
أو مع أشخاص يعرفون بعضهم البعض، زملاء عمل،
أو صديقيين، أو زوجين،
وعلى صعيد أكبر من هذا، مجموعات، مجتمعات،
أو دول،
تتعدى بدائرتها الحمراء على حرية أشخاص
آخريين، دول أخرى،
وهنا يمكننا أن نرى مقدار الدمار،
وكم من الأشخاص قد يتأثرون بسبب عدم
احترامي لهذه الدائرة الحمراء،
مجرد دائرة حمراء، لم أقم أنا باحترامها.
سؤالي الأول لحياة عظيمة تشبهك، هل ترى أن
دائرتك الحمراء واضحة في جميع علاقاتك؟
هل تفكر بلآخريين؟ أي هل تمتلك أخلاق؟
سؤالي الثاني، أعلم أن الأخلاق شيء جيد
ولكنها تقوم بتحديدي،
أي أنني لا أستطيع أن أخرج من هنا، ولكنني
لست مولوداً لأكون ممنوعاً،
أنا إنسان والإنسان مخلوق جميل، يحتاج ما
يجعله أكبر، ما يجعله شخص عظيم،
ما يجعله جميل، ليس بحاجة لشيء يقيدني.
لذلك ما الشيء الذي من الممكن أن يجعلني
شخص عظيم؟
البشرية منذ البداية قامت بالتفكير لغاية
اليوم، ما الشيء الذي يجعلنا عظماء؟
مثلاً صديقنا ماسلو، هل تذكرون هرم ماسلو؟
ماسلو قام بجمع كل احتياجتنا وقام بالتفكير
بجميع الأشياء التي تحفزنا كبشر،
وقام بترتيبها في هرم، في القاعدة قام بوضع
الأشياء البسيطة، أي الجسدية،
الطعام والشراب، ثم قام بالصعود قليلاً
باحتياجات البشرية، ليصل برأيه لأعظمها،
ألا وهي قمة الهرم وقام بتسميتها تحقيق
الذات.
من منظوره هذا ما يجعل الإنسان عظيم.
لنعود الى ما قبل ماسلو، قبله ب 2300 سنة،
لنرى أصدقائنا أفلاطون وأرسطو،
لقد قامو بالتفكير ما الذي يجعل الإنسان
عظيماً؟
في ذلك الزمان كانوا يقومون بتسمية هذه
الحالة من الرضى عن النفس "يودايمونيا".
حسناً ولكن الآن يا خليل أنت تريد مني أن
أكون عظيماً
عن طريق أن أقوم بتحقيق ذاتي من خلال قمة
هرم ماسلو وأن أعيش ال "يودايمونيا"؟
نعم، الجميل من هذا الكلام أن ما خلفه بسيط،
مفتاحه القيم.
نحن نسمع بالقيم كل يوم، عاداتنا، تقاليدنا،
وقيمنا،
ولكن أنا أعتقد أن القيم من الكلمات التي لم
تأخذ معناها الواضح،
وإذا قامت بأخذ معناها نحن لم نقم بأعطائها
أهميتها.
ما الشيء الذي يعطي الشخص قيمته؟
القيمة برأيي هي أي عمل أو أي فكرة تجعلني
برضى عن نفسي، تجعلني عظيم.
ياسمين شابسوغ كانت تقف هنا منذ قليل وكانت
تتكلم عن كرة القدم،
هل كانت تتكلم عن كرة القدم كما أعرفها؟
بالطبع لا.
كرة القدم بالنسبة لياسمين تعطيها تقديرها
لذاتها، تجعلها راضية، وتساعد فيها الأشخاص.
بالنسبة لياسمين كرة القدم هي قيمة، هي شيء
عظيم، تقوم بتحقيق ذاتها بها.
هل يجب أن أقوم بلعب كرة القدم لكي أمتلك
قيم؟ بالطبع لا،
الموضوع شخصي جداً، أنا أخاف من ألعب كرة
القدم، إذا كُسرت ما الذي سوف يقوم بتصليحي؟
(ضحك)
ولكن، هل جميعاً نعلم ما الشيء الذي نمتلك
الشغف له ولكننا قد نكون قد نسيناه؟
السؤال هو ما الشيء الذي تحب أن تعمل به
يومياً، من دون مقابل، لنهاية حياتك؟
هذا قد يقوم بتذكيرك بشيء أنت شغوف به،
وهذا الشغف الذي تمتلكه مرتبط بقيمة تقوم
بتحقيق ذاتك لك.
السؤال الثاني، هل تعلم قيمك؟
هل تعلم كيف ستبني القيم الخاصة بك وتقوم
بجعلها منارة؟
أنا أريد أداة، أنت حدثتني يا خليل عن
الأرضية التي هي الأخلاق،
وحدثتني عن القيم التي في الأعلى،
ولكنني أحتاج لأداة،
لشيء أقوم بممارسته وعمله لأصل للأعلى.
هنا يمكننا القول أن الجميع ليسوا على علم
ما الذي تستطيع أن تفعله.
تخيل أنك تجلس في داخل غرفة، وعندما تريد أن
تنهض يصطدم رأسك بالسطح،
أي أن سقف الغرفة منخفض جداً،
وهذا ما نراه في العديد من الأشخاص، سقف
حياتهم منخفض جداً،
سقف حياتهم في العمل منخفض جداً،
سقف حياتهم في العلاقات منخفض جداً،
هذا خبر سيء، ولكن الخبر الجيد أنك تستطيع
أن تقوم برفع سقف غرفتك بيدك.
هنا أجد ثلاث شخصيات، أول شخصية متعلقة بهذا
السقف هي التي تتكبر،
الشخص المتكبر يرى رأسه خارج سقف الغرفة
أصلاً،
ليس رأسه فقط بل أنفه أعلى من الآخريين.
التعامل مع هذا الشخص صعب جداً،
وعادةً التعامل معه ليس مريحاً لأنه عادةً
يتعدى،
هل تذكرون جارنا اللطيف؟
أعتقد أنه في هذه الجهة.
الشخصية الثانية هي الشخصية صغيرة النفس،
الذي يعطي لنفسه قيمة أقل مما هي عليه
كإنسان،
قم بسؤال هذا الشخص أنت سيء بماذا؟
ما الشيء الذي يزعجك؟
سوف يخبرك أن تفتح مجلد، وقم بالعد، أولاً،
ثانياً، ثالثاً...
أنا هكذا، أنا لا أستطيع، أنا لا أمتلك،
أنا، أنا، أنا...
حسناً، أنت جيد بماذا؟ بماذا نجحت؟
سوف ينظر لك ويصمت، عندما تسأله بماذا أنت
جيد؟ لا يعلم! وهذه كارثة.
هناك شعرة دقيقة ما بينه وبين الشخصية التي
في المنتصف، الشخص الطبيعي،
يمتلك الشخص الطبيعي نقاط ضعف، لا يوجد شخص
كامل بيننا،
ولكن في نفس الوقت يعلم أنه يمتلك نقاط قوة،
لديه مواهب،
لديه مهارات كونها على مدار الوقت.
لنأخذ محمد صلاح كمثال بما أننا تكلمنا عن
كرة القدم،
محمد صلاح لاعب مصري وأصبح نجماً الآن،
محمد صلاح أرى أنه يقف هنا في المنتصف،
هل هو متكبر؟ بالطبع لا،
محمد صلاح ليس وليد البارحة، لنا نراه منذ
مدة من الزمن وكيف يتصرف مع الأشخاص،
أنه شخص غير متكبر أبداً، يرى دائرته بوضوح.
هل سقفه منخفض؟ عندما تسأله في مقابلة،
حدثني عن نفسك،
هل سيخبرك أنا لا أعلم كيف أتكلم الغة
الإنجليزية؟ بالطبع لا،
(ضحك)
محمد صلاح سوف يخبرك قم بإنزالي الى الملعب
وسوف أقوم بتسديد الأهداف،
أنا هنا في هذه المنطقة (القوة)،
أريد أن أعلم أين منطقتي لأقف بها لأنها هي
الأداة لأصل للأعلى.
هنا أبدأ أنا ببناء المنارة، وعندما أتكلم
عن الشغف،
وعندما أقوم بسؤال كل شخص عن شغفه،
سوف يقوم بالإجابة وسوف يمتلك جواب بأنه
يريد أن يقوم بتغير العالم هكذا،
أنا أريد أن أقوم بتغير محيطي هكذا،
والأهم من كل هذا أنني أريد أن أقوم بتغيير
نفسي هكذا،
هنا أتحول لمنارة، لشيء مفيد يترك بصمة ربما
لي وربما للذين هم حولي.
سؤالي الثالث، كيف تكون محمد صلاح؟
ما هي مواهبك ومهاراتك؟
لقد تعرفنا على ثلاث أمور، أخلاقي، قيمي،
مواهبي ومهاراتي،
ولكن هذه أمور ثابتة، معرفة جامدة،
هنا (العقل)،
كيف سوف أقوم بالتطبيق؟
هذه لقطة قمنا بأخذها لأنفسنا، وهي من أغلى
اللقطات،
لأن هذه اللقطة تعبر عن معرفتي بذاتي،
إذا لم أكن أعرف ذاتي فأنا جاهل،
وعندما أكون جاهل تجاه ذاتي،
الجاهل عدو نفسه،
فأنا عدو نفسي وأنا شرس.
إذا ما الذي علي فعله الآن؟ كيف استخدم
أخلاقي، قيمي، ومواهبي؟
في إحصائية لم نقم بنشرها بعد، لنشارك الآن
بنشرها،
لأنني لا أؤمن بالإحصائيات الخارجية أريد
أن نقوم نحن الآن بإحصائية،
لنرى كيف نقوم بتطبيق الثلاث أمور السابقة.
من ذهب الى النادي الرياضي ولو لمدة يوم
واحد فليقف.
لو سمحتم قفوا،
وانظروا حولكم، يوجد في
القاعة هنا 100 شخص،
على ما يبدو 95 شخص يقفون الآن.
حسناً، من أكمل في النادي الرياضي مدة أسبوع
الرجاء أن يبقى واقفاً،
من أكمل الشهر الرجاء أن يبقى واقفاً،
من أكمل الثلاث أشهر الرجاء أن يبقى واقفاً،
6 أشهر، سنة، سنة ونصف، سنيتن في النادي
الرياضي،
أريد أن أطلب من مدربي الرياضة ولاعبي كرة
القدم أن يستريحوا،
العدد الذي أكمل في النادي الرياضي تقريباً
5 أشخاص،
(ضحك)
تفضلوا بالجلوس شكراً لكم،
أريد أن أخبركم أيضاً أن هناك أشخاص من
الذين استمروا بالوقوف
لم يكملوا بالنادي الرياضي ولكنهم يحبون
أن يقفوا،
(ضحك)
(تصفيق)
بدأنا بنسبة 95% بدأوا في النادي الرياضي،
انتهينا بعد سنة ونصف بنسبة 5% فقط أكملوا.
النادي الرياضي من أجل صحتي، لا يوجد شيء
أهم من صحتي، صحتي أولوية،
ولكنها تخيلوا أولوية في قاع هرم ماسلو.
في العديد من الأوقات نهمل أولوياتنا، إذا
قمنا بأهمال صحتنا،
حيث أنه إذا عطل جسدنا أين سوف نسكن؟
ولكننا في نفس الوقت نقوم بنسيانها،
لذلك كيف هو تقديرنا لذاتنا وتحقيقنا لها؟
الرياضة ليست بشيء سهل، عليك أن تتعب وأن
تتعرق،
أي فعلياً وحرفياً عليك أن تمزق عضلاتك
لتنمو،
ونفس الشيء ينطبق على جميع أولوياتنا
المتبقية، كي أتابعها عليّ أن أصعد.
لا وجود لأولوية ولا يوجد شيء تستحقه سوف
يكون موجود في الأسفل!
فقط الماء هي ما تتدحرج في الأسفل.
نحن نصعد للأعلى! لأن ما نستحقه في الأعلى.
علي أن أصعد لصحتي، عملي، علاقاتي.
نعم إنه شيء متعب!
الأحصائية التي قمنا بها اليوم تثبت كلام
معلمي جون ماكسويل، يقول،
"أصعب شخص لتأثر عليه وتقوده هو نفسك".
سؤالي الرابع، هل تقود نفسك لأولوياتك
يومياً؟
وهل أنت على ثقة أن هذه الأولويات هي
أولويات؟
أنا لا أسكن وحدي، أنا موجود كمنارة، ولكن
هذه المنارة وحدها لا تقوم بفعل شيء،
واحد هو رقم صحيح ولكنه لوحده لا فائدة منه،
فالآن علي أن أبحث عن منارات مثلي،
تخيل هنا مكان عالي، منارة، تنير الأعلى،
وتريد أن تجلب المزيد من المنارات بجانبها،
هذا هو ما يحصل في العلاقات، عندما أعرف
قيمي،عندها استطيع أن أدخل بالعلاقات،
لأن القيم هي الشيء الأهم، وعندها أبحث عن
الأشخاص التي تمتلك قيم مشابهة لقيمي.
هل رأيتم زوجين قاما بالانفصال لأنه يحب
اللون الأصفر وهي تحب اللون الأخضر؟
لا، من المؤكد أنهم انفصلوا لأن هناك شيء
عظيم مختلف بينهما،
عندما تكون هي كريمة وهو بخيل!
هنا نقول بأن قيمهما متعاكسة، نقول أنه في
العلاقة لا توجد قيم مشتركة ومتشابهة،
إذاً الأولويات مختلفة، وعندما تحصل أي
مشكلة بينهما،
فلأنهما مختلفين في الأولويات الكبيرة،
سوف تكون العلاقة هزيلة، وسوف تكسر.
كلما كان هناك قيم مشتركة كان أفضل،
الحمدلله أنني وزوجتي نشترك في هذه القيم،
نحن الاثنان بخيلان.
(ضحك)
الآن أصبح لديك أداة ترشيح لأي علاقة لمعرفة
من هم الأشخاص الذين يشبهونني في علاقاتي،
من هم الأشخاص الذين يشبهونني في قيمي،
لأتوجه لتلك العلاقات وأؤثر بها وتؤثر بي.
حتى في الشركات، سوف تكون علاقة بينك وبين
الشركة التي سوف تعمل بها إذا كنت سوف تعمل،
في أول صفحة في التقرير السنوي للشركة، هناك
رؤيتنا، مهمتنا، قيمنا،
تخبرك أن هذا هو شكل الشركة، إذا كنت تشبهني
تعال.
طبعاً أحياناً الكلام يكون بدون مقابل!
الآن أصبح لدي طريقة لفلترة العلاقات التي
أنا بداخلها.
سؤالي الخامس لك، هل علاقاتك تشبه قيمك؟
الطريق لحياة عظيمة تشبهك سهل، ولكن ممتنع.
سهل عندما أعلم من أنا، والى أين أنا متجه،
وكيف أريد أن أذهب،
ولكن ممتنع لأنه في الأعلى، ليس سهلاً!
هذا الصعود للأعلى هو بداخلي، ليس خارجي،
هذا تحدي خارجي أريد أن أعيشه.
الروائي ابراهيم نصرالله يقول،
"في كل إنسان منا قمة عليه أن يصعدها وإلا
بقي في القاع مهما صعد من قمم أخرى".
استمتعوا بحياة عظيمة، بحياة تُشبهكم.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)